okay well firstly I'd like to thank you
for taking the time to give an interview
for West Michigan's fastest growing
junior high school publication the
Muskegon junior time so now mr. holder
I'm doing this for extra credit here so
don't be shy let it all hang out if
you'd give me a an exclusive scoop
that'd be particularly great but item
number one the fact that you're most
likely going to be fired
ya know everyone's saying that yeah more
specifically my dad's that during the
fast and furious ordeal you deliberately
allow guns to be sold to illegal buyers
including Mexican drug cartels in order
to quote unquote
brainwash the American people about guns
I never said that we need to do this
every day of the week and just really
brainwash people into thinking about
guns in a vastly different way now
that's right no comment yeah we'll come
back to that okay now let's talk about
Benghazi and this incident American
citizens were terrorized raided and
killed specifically an ambassador in
Benghazi Libya and you and your friends
in the administration blamed the
incident on an online video you can't be
serious hmm you'd have to ask Hillary
that's above my pay grade
measuring feet at Payless is above your
pay grade I'm noticing a disturbing
trend here you and your friends screw up
an American citizen is seen to die we're
I don't think you have that right what
what about a do I have wrong no one's
ever asked me that before how could
nobody have ever asked you that it's
just never come on okay okay let's move
on to another item here involving the
IRS so it says here that this
administration used the IRS as a
political tool specifically targeting
voices of opposition using target
keywords like Tea Party and Patriots no
that never happened okay we'll just add
compulsive liar on to the list here but
according to my research this is
actually a violation of a constitutional
amendment oh yeah the first one I think
you need to check your facts hey black
Ned Flanders I spent over four hours
researching this in the computer okay
the government can't tire
people based on content of speech I was
told this would be a friendly interview
maybe that's your problem Eric all of
your interviews our friendly interviews
maybe that's why you eric holder are a
monumental screw-up of epic proportions
no no calm down no the fact that you
still have a job is done founding to me
and I'm 12
give me to tell me that the Junior Miss
teen enzymes is the only publication to
ask you these questions
what about reporters at ABC CBS NBC PBS
what about CNN no the president over
there is actually married to Hillary's
deputy secretary anyway I don't think
you want to publish this interview oh
you bet your horrible grade school troll
looking stash I'll publish it not unless
you want everyone else in the sixth
grade to know you still sleep with a
Cabbage Patch doll how could you know
that how could you possibly know that
or that you take ballroom dancing
lessons with your mommy
Tuesdays and Thursdays have you been
listening in on my phone calls reading
my emails but but I'm pressed that's a
violation of another amendment in here
yeah still the first one you can't do
that you like to think so
oh you're the worst you win this round
but you've made an enemy out of me like
Flanders
[Music]